fake quotes that is quotations that are
attributed to an author that aren't
actually by them oftentimes by somebody
else instead are not something radically
new but they have become much more
prevalent in this internet age
people post and repost these sharing
them without ever checking sources they
incorporate them into blog pieces and
even into
books
there's a vast variety of videos out
there with fake quotes from important
philosophers ranging from plato to
aristotle to epictetus and all the way
on to the present
in this video we're going to look at 10
of the
most egregious
of these fake quotes that are attributed
falsely to aristotle
we begin with this one that i'm sure
many of you have seen before tolerance
and apathy are the last
virtues of a dying society is this by
aristotle no definitely not my aristotle
and there's good reasons why not there
are variations out there like tolerance
is the last virtue of a depraved society
which is attributed to the evangelical
preacher dr james kennedy variations on
this have been shared and re-shared
throughout you could call it the right
wing internet sphere because this is
really about promoting intolerance of
different sorts
how do we know that this hasn't been
said somewhere by aristotle well
tolerance is really something that
becomes an issue and a term in the
modern period it's not something that
you would find
in his texts so people are
reading it backwards in there they're
making him say things that aristotle
himself would not be inclined to say
society is another word that aristotle
wouldn't be using he would be thinking
in terms of a city-state or
polis or political community which is
how we typically translate that term
here's our second fake quote attributed
falsely to aristotle knowing yourself is
the beginning of all wisdom and what is
this this is a mish-mosh of the famous
delphic maxim
know yourself and claiming that it's the
beginning of wisdom that's sort of an
add-on here aristotle doesn't say this
and he wouldn't say this because he has
a differing conception of what sofia or
wisdom would be and it doesn't begin
with knowing yourself but rather has to
do with the things that are unchanging
are you an unchanging eternal element of
the universe i don't think so so this is
clearly a fake quote
the third one is also a kind of mishmash
the more you know the more you know you
don't know and this is kind of similar
to what
socrates is saying in plato's apology
you know he's claiming that at least he
knows what he doesn't know or he's wise
because he knows what he doesn't know as
opposed to other people who think that
they know but this is not aristotle
again this is something that is being
attributed to him i'm not quite sure why
somebody thought that they ought to
attribute this to aristotle but it's not
by him
our fourth one is at least rooted in
something that aristotle does say but
it's rather garbled and shows perhaps a
need to
talk a little bit more and say something
that aristotle himself
didn't say happiness is the meaning and
purpose of life the whole aim of human
existence this isn't completely wrong
from an aristotelian point of view but
aristotle doesn't talk about human
existence and he doesn't say that
happiness is the
meaning of life that again very modern
terminology that is coming in you could
say that he does think that happiness is
the purpose the telos the end of life
but he's not saying the rest of this and
you have to ask yourself why would
somebody get aristotle
mixed up like this
this fifth one similarly gets aristotle
partly right and then attributes
something that goes completely against
what aristotle thinks to him character
is made by many acts it may be lost by a
single one
in the case of this quote we do have
somebody who we can hang it on a
reverend j a hay
found in
great thoughts from master minds he was
a methodist minister apparently and why
is this not something that aristotle
would say i mean character is made by
many acts for aristotle or rather habit
is made from that and then character is
closely related to habit can it be lost
by a single action that is
very unaristotelian and to claim that
this is aristotle's position shows that
one entirely misunderstands one of the
most central tenets
of aristotelian ethics
here's another very popular one and this
one has zero connection to aristotle
there is only one way to avoid criticism
do nothing say nothing and be nothing
now with this one we know exactly where
it comes from albert hubbard's little
journeys to the homes of american
statesmen and the passage runs if you
would escape moral and physical
assassination do nothing say nothing be
nothing court obscurity for only in
oblivion does safety lie and in
hubbard's later writings he reworked the
statement so that's exactly where this
one is coming from why couldn't it be
aristotelian well aristotle doesn't talk
about trying to avoid criticism let
alone give you advice about how to do so
and he certainly
wouldn't tell you to do nothing or to
say nothing and to be nothing these
especially the be nothing
very modern way of looking at things
that's not very congruous with
aristotle's own
thought and writing
here's another one that we know comes
from somebody else you will never do
anything in this world without courage
it is the greatest quality of the mind
next to honor
this is from a book by james lane allen
called the choir invisible and it's not
that difficult to find the exact
quotation from it
why wouldn't aristotle have said
anything like this well courage could be
considered a quality but it wouldn't be
considered a quality of the mind
aristotle would have considered it to be
a habit that is established in the
feeling or passionate or desirous part
of the soul and he wouldn't say that
it's the greatest one of all the virtues
because there's plenty of others as well
that are equally great or perhaps even
greater for example justice or
magnanimity
he also wouldn't say that it's the
greatest quality of the mind next to
honor because aristotle thinks that
although honor is indeed a good it is
not the good virtue is something that is
deserving of honor and is greater than
honor so to think that this is
aristotelian one would have to be as
with many of the earlier ones completely
mistaken about aristotelian ethics
this eighth one is an occasion for some
humor it is during our darkest moments
that we must focus to see the light now
this is by aristotle it's just not by
our aristotle because it's attributed to
a 20th century aristotle namely
aristotle onassis not aristotle the
philosopher and why would aristotle the
philosopher say anything so silly and
trite and new agey as this
speaking of rather superficial and trite
sayings this ninth one i think fits that
bill educating the mind without
educating the heart is no education at
all now we can find some statements like
this in the
1800s that talk about educating the mind
without educating the heart nobody's
quite sure how this came to be
attributed to aristotle but in the last
several decades it certainly seems to
have caught hold why would aristotle
never have said anything remotely like
this aristotle is quite interested in
education but there is no mind versus
heart distinction in aristotle as a
matter of fact aristotle in his physical
understanding of psychology thought that
the heart was indeed where the mind was
located so it wouldn't make any sense
for him to talk about this aristotle
also doesn't talk about educating the
mind or the heart but rather educating a
person
our tenth is a statement the provenance
of which nobody really knows as far as i
can tell be a free thinker and don't
accept everything you hear as truth be
critical and evaluate what you believe
in this is clearly not from aristotle
and it's attributed to him by many
people who are going against the very
advice that is being given here because
they are accepting something as truth
namely that this is by aristotle and
they are failing to be critical or to
evaluate what they are wrongly believing
in aristotle wouldn't have spoken about
these matters in this way notice that we
have imperatives being used here be a
free thinker don't accept everything you
hear is truth be critical evaluate in
aristotle's text we don't often see
this sort of advice being given in fact
if there is advice it's usually one
should do this sort of thing it's not
framed like this at all being a free
thinker is a later idea aristotle does
talk about being free but not as a
thinker and of course anybody can say
don't accept everything you hear as
truth that's a truism being critical in
the sense that we're seeing here is not
how aristotle would have talked about
matters so this one is clearly false as
well
we have an 11th bonus fake quote which
we might see as not being
as fake as all of these other quotes no
great mind has ever existed without a
touch of
madness
and this one is attributed to aristotle
by another philosopher who is coming
centuries later and that is seneca we
don't have anything like this in
aristotle's existing texts there could
be the possibility that seneca has not
misremembered or made up something and
that there
was a statement like this in aristotle's
texts that we've lost but we don't
really know and to attribute it
uncritically to aristotle as so many
people are accustomed to do is to
at least in a formal sense
engage in making a fake quote
but maybe we have a little bit of
leniency with this one
as we finish up with our exercise of
debunking fake quotes about aristotle
here there's a few more general
guidelines that i'd like to impart to
you as advice or exhortations so the
first of these is to exercise healthy
suspicion just because it's out there
and attributed to somebody doesn't mean
that they actually said that and you
should be suspicious of anything that
doesn't sound quite right if you know
that something is a fake quote don't
repost it and if you don't know that
it's not a fake quote you probably
shouldn't be reposting it either or
incorporating it into your work this
leads to the third guideline demand the
sources demand it of those who are
posting quotes say where is this
actually located in aristotle's or
marcus aurelius's or plato's text where
do they actually say this demand it of
yourself as well this ties together with
the second if you actually ask yourself
can i find the passage that this is
coming from and a real passage a sourced
passage not just something that people
are themselves repeating over and over
without ever truly attributing to the
person the last thing i'll say is that i
have drawn upon a website in doing this
that i want to acknowledge called
sentence
antiqua and they have a quite a few
things about fake quotes including a
hierarchy of types of fake quotes you
should check them out so this is the
first in what are going to be hopefully
an entire series of videos going through
fake quotes on important authors
you